between the two of us who's more
attractive oh definitely you Oh God you
said that
yeah today's topic we're gonna pop in
truth or drink by the cut since we
reacted Jubilee so much we try to switch
it up go to another content however this
is not gonna be a cringe report because
this well actually we don't know what
its gonna be
don't forget to subscribe to a page gone
all right I'm TJ I'm jasmine i'm suppr
cetera she from a final fantasy game
what was that cetera she even got an
anime looking head she's wider than the
backdrop do you know how anime
characters all have the same faces but
they have different color hair to
differentiate okay cetera and Reilly you
know when you get like a exotic as name
and then you get some ordinary it's like
sticking of mango beside oatmeal it's
like if there were siblings I really
liked the first one better how long have
you had a crush on me seven ish yeah I
just wish she would have told me earlier
because I was super insecure in high
school and you could have boosted my
confidence I would like you tell me
before because you know I'm that and you
know I get more confidence Rob did not
go what I thought it was gonna go when
she said I just wish you would have told
me earlier
oh my all maybe she used to have a Chris
hundred then she said so I was super
insecure in high school I'm like oh oh
oh because you think he would have had a
better shot with you then this is so
cool we started talking a couple months
ago cuz I cast him for a photo shoot and
now we're here yes yes more she asked me
if I only wanna date and I guess this is
women's
Oh since the day I saw your Instagram I
think what drew me to you was that like
you weren't all in my face and like hey
and I get that I get that often so like
it was kind of cool that you played it
cool sure yeah it's kind of cool you
like played it cool and just like satin
the friendzone forever
yeah so great Cheers we can like go
drinking - you and I can just tell you
about all the guys that I hook up with
while you sit there and you just cry
yourself to sleep later on at night yeah
cheers from I do Hillary from Fresh
Prince yeah but not without this between
the two of us who's more attractive oh
definitely you oh I'm glad you said that
yeah if you know you look good you don't
know you're good and it's a fact she
looks better than he does so I'm at it
it's rough it's in your face but I kind
of like you like that
here's a problem what when you say that
I know I'm good-looking and you're not
very charismatic people are gonna look
at you like you're not even if it is
true that is how people view you I
guarantee you if I blow in the comments
people who be mad at this sure but she's
right I feel like I'm pretty attractive
definitely definitely yeah fine as hell
we talk about looks like two young
people in a young couple so I you hang
up no you hang up no you hang up you in
what is your favorite position and why
[Music]
she's looking out like tell me but
you're never gonna get to try it on
we're never gonna get it never gonna get
it never gonna get never gonna get it
never gonna get never gonna get it never
gonna get it probably like the standing
Donnie yeah it's a good one
oh if I was really you
what's the first thing you'd ask me to
do free yourself you don't deserve to be
my slave milady I feel like he's a white
knight like that yeah I guarantee you
she gets smashed by [ __ ] damn see
she's disappointed that he doesn't tell
you she's disappointed that this guy
doesn't know how can you treat her as a
slave what am i watching no guarantee I
would definitely have you eat me out
while I play video games I was attracted
[Laughter]
definitely have you on the train drop on
the train
okay you are freak freak you okay is off
the rails yeah I'm at it
here's the thing right like when you a
very nice dude and some broads like like
submissive submissiveness you never
gonna have a chance do you like that
assertiveness that you gotta be a
certain like I can't say no I'm not sure
I need you to take a drink that's man I
know everyone's gonna rag on her because
he's so like shy and passive and she's
being like a bit like assertive but
that's what she likes she likes
assertive
and this guy's being so passive it's
kind of pathetic to box with you I'm
more mad at the dude for being so
pathetic and then to be into a girl
who's nothing like him
look she told him take a drink and like
a little she did because this guy's so
deep in the friend zone he's six feet
under it
he doesn't know he's in the friend zone
no rough he's in the basement the SIP
song yeah I wish I knew the answer being
a nice and timid guy is not a problem
but understand that if that girl you're
not her type don't waste your time do
you want kids
yeah eventually I would like to have to
suck out names picked out in my head
whoever I'm with is gonna have to accept
that I'm gonna name the boys she can
name the girls okay works for me
I want zero kids really no kids I'm not
a kid person I've never seen any Final
Fantasy characters have kids you gotta
save the world so when you busy doing
others you can't have time to have you
know what shut up to you yeah cuz it's
hard for women to say that they openly
don't want kids yeah I would never date
a girl who doesn't point is about you uh
definitely doggy or it's a would it be
like a reverse town I like on the couch
there like like where there's like half
I can see right no that's a pretty good
one listen that's a good one depends on
the chemistry between it but yo I've had
some good I was just like this is you
know certain positions that you think
you're never gonna like because you
Nishal ii try them out and you hate them
using put then you we encounter a
certain broad and just the [ __ ] are you
like oh I didn't know I could hear mmm
well you could because you did yes and I
gave her a high five I was like jump I'm
changing mine no no that happened once
changed my life yeah I'm changing mine
okay I like that one either
there's certain position I used to do
there's a gold one yeah
say hi as well you can watch it what's
the kinkiest thing you've done in the
bedroom really and BUTT STUFF everything
I said has been confirmed but I need two
lies she went a little bit further
what's the kinkiest thing you've done in
the bedroom I'm really into but Soleil
plugs and I'm trying to reach a certain
goal
haven't gotten there yet but I'm trying
to do it
[Music]
yeah I like that how about you that's
the kinkiest thing you've done
[Music]
after you heard that just look her
straight in the eyes say blood stuff
it's not only that she's disappointed
she's getting mad
you know what that face is no I don't
worry contempt hmm
I'm telling you you sound boring but
then again hold on
what would it be if we switch the roles
coz when a girl says stuff like that is
because she's liberated when a guy would
say like that he's being progressive or
he's being a his people he's you don't
do bust off it's so boring
it wouldn't go so well if it was the
opposite the guy would get whole lot
more flat then she is what's just fun
cuz when girls say [ __ ] like that that's
to liberation but what man says like
that they're perfect but whatever do you
think I don't like it's like when you
crush after someone when you know you're
not their type is like why are you
wasting your time I know some girls who
like really classy preppy dudes I'm not
gonna go after them cuz I dress like a
bum it is what it is right if I know
that's what they go for all the time I'm
not gonna be like please please I'm not
their type keep it movin be why would
you crush after I don't get that's
stupid to me
I dare you to kiss me on the lips or
take a shot
[Music]
yes
no hesitation let's go no hesitation in
it that's how I like to see it Rainbow
six reveling in listen the doors were
closed to you were deep in that friend
zone and a little light was shown and
and Moses parted the Red Sea and out of
the red zone you begin to see the light
and you took it and you grab those lips
and you engage in beautiful sin thank
you
yes my [ __ ] I feel like the ends up in
this part of the Red Sea for my [ __ ]
Moses drowned him okay Pharaoh came back
and he got drowned my boy did not make
it on Noah's Ark he definitely drowned
god bless you Wow she drank that so fast
to make a statement 21 gun salute a
little liquor on a scale of 1 to 10 how
good of a kisser am I see you only gave
me like a 5 second sample trial 1 I'm
about to subscribe
o year this guy knows yeah where's the
nearest training let's go I was like a
strong eight for like just just a little
bit I was like oh she better not be one
of them knowing bronze when you know
they all do this
yeah really yeah [ __ ] in the comments
who dated tell me what happens when you
rate
to go on anything and tell me with you
if you're honest and modest tell me they
don't we like I'm not a tear I'm not a
ten you're triggered I'm not a 10 if I
asked to go y'all have been looking at
my shoes like I said I'm like thank you
God bless you see that girl were you
guys more or less than to each other
after this I think more I'd hang out
with you again
yeah likewise I know hang out okay
here's my advice to do stop seeing her
bro you need to work on whatever you are
going on or find someone else is more up
your alley but if you are not her type
you don't know she's not interested in
you you don't have to work on nothing if
that's who you are as a person this girl
is not for you that's it no I don't
think you have to work on anything cuz
that would be disingenuous of who you
are if that is who you are
move the gone that's right that is just
not you tell that's that's it I'm not
gonna work on nothing she's still
looking at him with contempt still do it
cuz they have a tendency to romanticize
so there's still that there's still that
that hmm we can hang out but mmm because
no it's because she sees a mess pathetic
and any woman that deems you pathetic
will look at you with contempt hmm
especially if you try to hang around
them all the time go to play truth or
drink calm and buy the game and play it
yeah and you can do this [ __ ] off camera
so you can actually get wild with it you
had the option to but
you are not she looked the way she
looked that isn't like the way she
looked at him like [ __ ] you out of all
people cannot talk about nothing being
wild listen if you are hearing you stuck
in the friend zone friend zone okay you
buying this girl stuff you listen to her
problems you find out she dudes and you
not again something you desperately want
sup boo boo you're in the Simpson and
it's pathetic and I look down on you get
the [ __ ] up I don't like that time and
it just it makes me sad for it I'm
compassionate but at the same time like
it's pathetic
pick yourself up and move on so anyways
we want to hear your thoughts what did
you guys think
shout out to my other boy he was in the
friend zone and took advantage and he
went in went in I respect that
anyways that's it for today's video we
want to hear your comments below and
don't forget to subscribe on patreon if
you want to and we also have the podcast
I preach podcast check that out
[Music]
you should do it or drink mean you one
day yeah hi but then we would have to
include the viewers do like the live
stream life yeah okay I'm mad at that
yeah I'm setting this [ __ ] up okay
I don't drink on average how many dates
do you go on before you sleep with
somebody - three - wanted to get to know
and then one to get to know I will have
on the first date did you hear what she
said she'd say yeah you know I would
have I would have on the first day no
she said I will have my first day that's
what happened it's just on you I will
have on the first date this girl took
her own breath away oh no no what is it
four inches what's that 1/4 inches al
pacino football we don't know one told
the difference between winning and
losing
he's four inches sometimes you can't
tear too slow sometimes too quick huh
but I want you to look at everyone in
this room you look at him and understand
that what we have right here means
something something more than what they
have out there four inches that's all it
is guys the difference between winning
and losing four inches swimmers all I
got pretty good right it wasn't a four
inches I don't know what it was I don't
know what you're talking it's a couple
inches something